Anomalous creatures in the SCP Foundation’s
universe are not a rarity.
Dealing with anomalous sapient lifeforms is
the Foundation’s bread and butter - whether
it’s a talkative sea slug or a body-stealing
swarm of ants.
For those of you who haven’t read their
Ethics Committee guidebooks, sapient anomalies
are defined as creatures who have a keen sense
of self-awareness and can communicate.
From the zaniness of Doctor Bright and his
amulet to the neck-cracking SCP-173, these
sapient anomalous entities come in all shapes
and sizes.
But when does a creature become so sapient
they can be considered anomalous?
Take the humble octopus for example, who also
just so happens to be the subject of today’s
video, the octopus is a boneless, eight-legged
creature capable of shifting the color and
texture of its skin, and will blast predators
with a black substance to blind them.
If I read that in an SCP Foundation file,
I might think those researchers found an alien
creature, but no, octopi – or octopodes,
are, as you know, real living breathing creatures
you can see at any aquarium.
Another interesting quirk of octopodes is
their intelligence.
These creatures are smart, extremely smart,
hell, they will even use fallen coconuts as
a sort of armor against enemies.
If tool use isn’t intelligence, I don’t
know what is.
You may be wondering, how can you make an
octopus more anomalous than what I’ve already
described.
Well, today on SCP Explained, we will be taking
a look at SCP-2967 – The Sapient Cephalopods
- to answer that exact question.
We’ve all probably been to aquariums, dark,
ambient rooms where the only light comes from
behind the massive tanks filled to the brim
with colorful fish and crustaceans.
They can be fun to explore, but when you’ve
seen a bunch of exotic fish once, it’s not
like you’re clamoring to get back in soon.
This was the problem faced by the Galaxy Aquarium
in May of 2010 – attendance was low, and
profit was lower.
The owner of the Aquarium was a man by the
name of Mark Hemphill.
He was young and extremely ambitious.
Mark had an interest in marine life since
when he was a child and dedicated his life
to studying the creatures of the sea.
When he opened the aquarium, he had just gotten
out of college.
He hoped his passion and his aquarium would
inspire even just one child to pursue the
study of marine life as he did.
Mark’s ambitious personality was not going
to let him watch his life’s work go to waste.
At a nearby auction house, the anomalous Group
of Interest Marshall, Carter, and Dark were
organizing a showing for their new batch of
anomalous creatures available for bidding.
Seasoned viewers of SCP Explained have likely
run into anomalies that Marshall, Carter,
and Dark have had a hand in.
For those not in the loop, Marshal, Carter,
and Dark are dealers of anomalous goods and
services, selling anomalies to the highest
bidder no matter who they are, from the average
Joe to a tyrannical dictator, Marshall, Carter,
and Dark only care about cold hard cash and
getting as much of it as they can.
Mark, hearing whispers of a massive auction
coming up, decided to attend.
He entered the auction house, an old, dilapidated
warehouse on the sketchy side of town.
Not exactly inspiring confidence, but Mark
thought maybe, just maybe, there would be
something for him to add to his aquarium to
get more attendees.
Mark walked through the heavy metal doors
into an immaculate auction space.
The building was loaded with well-dressed
individuals who gazed over the items they
had for sale.
Wooden tables lined the walls of the warehouse,
and on top of each table were tanks and cages
of creatures Mark never thought could exist,
from dogs that smelled like candles to purple
frogs that telepathically communicated with
the people around them.
Mark was convinced that there was something
here he could use.
A staff member approached Mark almost immediately;
it was as if the staff could smell the willingness
to spend money on him.
She was an older woman, dressed in a fine
purple-hued suit.
She spoke with a comforting candor to Mark,
asking him about his day and what brought
him to the auction house.
She introduced herself as “J” and said
that the auction house had just the thing
for Mark before he could even get the words
out.
They walked to the opposite side of the building,
where a purple curtain was erected.
Walking through, it was as if Mark has returned
back to his aquarium.
What were the odds that this place would have
a marine life section?
Oddly, for such a well-designed room, there
was only one small tank placed in it.
Within it was six Octopodes, a pale yellow
in color – Mark immediately recognized the
species as the Common Octopus.
The Galaxy Aquarium already had a cephalopod
section with much more rare species than the
Common Octopus.
Dejected, Mark almost gave up hope before
J approached the tank and kneeled.
J seemed concerned, then called out the name
Levi.
From under the table on which the tank stood,
a massive octopus slithered into sight, startling
Mark.
It was at least 5 feet in height and length.
That’s impossible, Mark thought, there’s
no way that an octopus of this species could
get to be this large.
The octopus’ size was not the only oddity
it held, though.
J began to scold Levi for leaving its tank
and asked it what it had to say for itself.
She threw a sharpie marker to the ground for
Levi, who uncapped it and began to write out
the word “SORRY” on the concrete floor.
This couldn’t be, Mark thought, there’s
absolutely no way that an octopus can learn
to understand English, let alone write it.
J turned to Mark, encouraging him to talk
to Levi.
“What is your name?”
Mark asked sheepishly.
He couldn’t believe he was trying to talk
to an octopus.
As soon as the words left his mouth, the octopus
spelled out L-E-V-I with its marker.
Mark couldn’t believe it.
This had to be some trick, right?
Some sort of marketing gimmick to get him
to buy an overgrown piece of calamari.
There is no way that an octopus could have
self-awareness.
Mark knew they were smart, of course, he had
studied these things for years, but knowing
its name… that’s not possible.
“What are you?”
Mark questioned, hoping to figure out if it
was an animatronic instead of a living breathing
animal.
Levi began to write on the floor again.
Not a word this time, but a symbol.
The octopus fist drew a large oval, then eight
lines coming from the bottom – a crude drawing
of an octopus.
Behind Levi, the other six octopodes were
watching him as spectators, seeming to clap
when Levi finished the drawing.
J, with a smug grin on her face, asked Mark
if he was impressed.
The look on Mark’s face already told the
story, so J began to go over the pricing of
the creatures.
Levi and the other six octopodes were a package
deal, with the starting bid for all seven
placed at 3000 dollars.
Mark, without a second thought, asked if he
could outright purchase Levi and his compatriots
for ten thousand dollars.
J’s smile grew wider, and she shook Mark’s
hand without another word said.
Levi and the six other octopodes were delivered
to the Galaxy Aquarium the next day.
Within that time, Mark had already prepared
an unused section for the arrival of his new
attraction.
The cephalopods were placed in their tanks
without much difficulty and settled into their
new home.
Advertising began for the Galaxy Aquarium’s
newest attraction “The Talking Octopus”
– Mark even splurged on a billboard on the
nearby highway.
This investment was meant to save the aquarium,
and for the next few months, attendance skyrocketed.
Now we know why the SCP Foundation keeps a
heavy watch over anomalous entities in the
public because all it takes is one ambitious
person before the entire world knows that
anomalies exist.
With the popularity of Levi, it was a matter
of time before the SCP Foundation heard of
it.
It was time for an investigation.
Site-12 was a site dedicated to Marine Life,
and as such, many of the personnel stationed
there had the appropriate expertise to deal
with the anomaly.
Agent Hooper volunteered for the investigation;
he was ordered to pose as an animal behavior
specialist from the Sea Coral Pacific Federation
- Real creative there, SCP Foundation.
It just so happened that at the same time
Agent Hooper was getting involved, Levi was
beginning to give Mark a hard time at his
aquarium.
It was a late night in January 2011.
The aquarium had since closed after another
day of almost full attendance.
Levi was not sleeping, however, he was hungry
and by coincidence, the section of the Galaxy
Aquarium next to Levi’s tank was a potential
all you could eat buffet should his plan come
to fruition.
The next day, aquarium staff awoke to the
filtration system of the crab enclosure being
blocked by one of Levi’s friends.
It was quickly removed and placed back into
its proper tank.
It wasn’t out of the ordinary for Octopodes
to escape their tanks; as I explained, they’re
smart creatures.
Aquarium staff began the process of moving
the crabs to a temporary tank while repairs
and cleaning on the original tank were taking
place.
As their attention was drawn to the damaged
filter and contaminated crab tank, Levi managed
to escape and enter the unguarded temporary
tank of the crabs.
Broken shells and water splattered the floor
of the temporary tank room as the feast began.
It was a massacre.
Levi ate 20 of the 40 crabs and another 10
were dropped off into the octopus tank for
Levi’s comrades.
Satisfied with its meal, Levi returned to
his tank as if nothing had happened.
An hour passed before the leftovers of Levi’s
dinner were discovered, and it didn’t take
much guessing on the part of Aquarium staff
to deduce who was behind this.
Agent Hooper arrived the next day and asked
to meet with Mark.
Hooper explained that he was from the Sea
Coral Pacific Federation and his place of
employment had heard of Levi and wanted to
study them.
Mark, like a moth to a flame, eagerly took
the opportunity to describe the remarkable
events of the previous day.
Hooper nodded along with the story and promised
to figure out why Levi was acting this way.
Agent Hooper was escorted to the Talking Octopus
section of the aquarium and asked for some
privacy, which he was granted.
Levi was sitting on a large mound of sand
while the smaller octopodes sat in front of
it as if they were intently listening.
Levi was apparently lecturing the group, using
a sharp rock to carve words and pictures on
the plexiglass walls of the tank.
Agent Hooper knocked on the glass, startling
the group.
In anger, Levi swam to the front of the tank
and stared at Agent Hooper.
With a tentacle, it knocked hard on the glass
and then endeavored to return to its lecture.
Agent Hooper didn’t catch the hint that
he was unwelcome, and stayed uncomfortably
close to the glass until Levi couldn’t ignore
the agent any longer.
The octopus held up five tentacles and made
a shooing motion towards Hooper, who was incredibly
surprised.
Hooper recognized that motion as the phrase
“go away” in sign language.
Hooper, in response, asked Levi “Sign Language?”
in sign language.
In response, Levi once again held up five
tentacles and created what appeared to be
a fist, then bobbed it back and forth like
a head nodding.
An octopus that knows sign language – not
the most dangerous or extraordinary anomaly
the Foundation has ever discovered, but still,
this anomaly could not remain out of containment.
Hooper quickly contacted the research head
at Site-12 and explained the situation; he
needed a containment van for an aquatic anomaly,
a containment force, and class A amnestics
immediately.
This request was granted.
Foundation Mobile Task Force Lambda-12, "Pest
Control", stormed the building and wrangled
the aquarium staff into a closet so they couldn’t
interfere.
The agents were dressed in their tactical
armor and held large rifles, but this was
only to show that they were meant to be taken
seriously, and not to be used for force.
A white, unmarked containment van arrived
soon after.
Foundation researchers ran into the building
and transported Levi and his students into
the temporary tanks of the containment van,
and made sure they were securely closed and
locked multiple times.
When each octopus was secured, an airborne
version of A-Class Amnestics was distributed
throughout the aquarium by the Mobile Task
Force agents leading to all knowledge of Levi
being forgotten by the aquarium staff and
Mark.
For further containment, the SCP Foundation
distributed liquid amnestics into the city’s
water supply, so that anyone who saw one of
Levi’s performances would forget that it
ever happened.
The SCP Foundation classified Levi as SCP-2967
and discovered the full extent of its anomalous
attributes.
SCP-2967 of course has the ability to communicate
through written language, is able to recognize
and identify colors, symbols, and individual
features of other species, and holds an abnormally
high intellect, almost comparable to an average
human’s intelligence.
The six comrades of SCP-2967 were designated
as SCP-2967-1, as they do not seem to be at
the same level of intellect as SCP-2967.
Through behavioral analysis and research,
it was found that SCP-2967 will refer to SCP-2967-1
as its students, friends, or army.
Dr. Reynard, the head researcher on the SCP-2967
anomaly, began hosting “intelligence checkups”
on SCP-2967 every two weeks.
These consisted of Levi talking to Dr. Reynard
through the use of a waterproof magnetic slate
while the doctor asked Levi questions.
On one such occasion, the Foundation discovered
that there may be more creatures similar to
SCP-2967 and its students.
Doctor Reynard began by drawing a crab, an
octopus, and SCP-2967’s toy.
He labeled them CRAB and FRIEND and TOY.
On its slate, SCP-2967 wrote “like” and
then a sketch of a heart.
Dr. Reynard drew a checkmark on his clipboard,
before rewarding SCP-2967 with a prawn.
Following up, Dr. Reynard asked if there was
anything Levi didn’t like.
To display this concept, Dr. Reynard drew
an X over a heart symbol.
Levi paused for a moment, seeming to think,
then drew what appeared to be a bird with
outstretched wings and an angular beak.
Upon finishing the drawing, the octopus’
skin changed to a deep red color
Levi wrote “Dont know word” on his slate,
then returned to its normal colorization.
Reynard displayed a photo of a pigeon to Levi,
who marked an X on his slate, signifying that
there was something wrong before shifting
its skin black.
In response, Dr. Reynard returned a picture
of a crow to Levi, who scrambled to write
on its slate.
“That ! Word ?” it wrote hastily.
Reynard responded “CROW.”
With his newfound knowledge, Levi drew a heart
with an X through it on its slate, then spelled
out “DONT LIKE CROW !” Doctor Reynard
was confused.
How do two species of creatures who live in
completely different habitats have a disdain
for each other?
SCP-2967 began to explain.
Levi sketched an octopus, a crow, and what
appeared to be a human.
Over the head of the human, Levi drew an arrow
pointing at the human, before drawing a checkmark
over the sketch of the octopus and the crow.
Levi connected the checkmarks to the arrow
above the human with two lines.
It seemed that the crows and the octopodes
disdain come from their common ability to
connect and grow fond of humans.
The intelligence check concluded after Levi
explained this to Doctor Reynard, as the octopus
claimed it was tired and wanted to return
to its containment chamber.
The next day, however, it seemed that SCP-2967
had correctly predicted what would happen
at Site-12
On April 3rd, 2011, research staff at Site
12 reported a high concentration of American
Crows surrounding the building.
Many were perched in trees or on the roof
of the site, but some were simply hovering
near the entrances, seeming to hope that the
door would open.
While the crows weren’t aggressive to humans,
they would fly to a window connected to the
containment chamber of SCP-2967 and peck on
it.
This continued for hours, and it seems that
the crows were threatening Levi and its friends.
The Foundation deployed Mobile Task Force
Lambda-4 "Birdwatchers” to Site 12.
This team was not armed in your standard tactical
gear and heavy weaponry, they wore camouflage
clothing, with shoes that muffled their footsteps
in grassy environments.
They had jackets of thick leather to prevent
injuries from talons or beaks, and they had
specialized pellet guns they used to incapacitate
anomalous birds.
They began by shooing the birds away and captured
a few using nets for further study.
As they concluded, all but one of the crows
dispersed.
This crow was, similar to Levi, much larger
compared to nonanomalous members of its species.
The large crow flew ten feet from the entrance
of the site, and spat the decaying remains
of one Common Octopus out onto the asphalt
parking lot, before retreating.
The Birdwatchers attempted to follow the group
of crows but the flock was impossible to track.
What was found, however, was an area in a
nearby forest that contained an abnormally
large number of feathers belonging to the
American Crow species, as well as numerous
small, makeshift huts made of sticks and dying
leaves, and a collection of various litter
fashioned into basic tools, such as hammers
made of bolts and toothbrushes.
The most surprising item retrieved during
this exploration was the torn remains of a
copy of the documentation for SCP-2967, kept
in the largest hut.
As is standard, the SCP Foundation enacted
surveillance procedures on this location,
placing hidden cameras and microphones, as
well as traps.
The large crow has been classified as SCP-2967-B.
So, it seems that the animal kingdom is at
war for the favor of the human race.
While the Foundation only knows for sure that
octopodes and crows are at battle, there may
be many more species out there who look to
curry our favor.
Who do you think will be the victor should
battle commence?
Now go check out “SCP-247 - A Harmless Kitten”
and “SCP-1111 - The White Dog” for more
anomalous animals that defy expectations!